one of the greatest things about pax
east is the huge India mega booth where
all the independent developers come from
all over the world and show off their
games to the public and a game i saw
this year is also a game i saw last year
but it's still one of my favorites it's
severed from drinkbox studios from
toronto these are the studio that made
guacamelee that sort of mexican style
which door side-scrolling platformer
separate is very different it's a
dungeon crawler but it uses a very
similar visual style to guacamelee it's
very colorful lots of big shapes but
really expressive at the same time so
severed is a touch-based game which
might not sound like everyone's cup of
tea but this is actually a frantic kind
of a combat experience when you're
playing it so essentially what you do is
you swipe in different directions to cut
off enemy body parts but when you're
facing more than one enemy you actually
have to rotate the camera there are
little dials that tell you you know how
long you have to wait until the next
enemy attack comes in so you're
constantly turning attacking and
juggling and you know using time
management in order to succeed it's also
got a lot of RPG mechanics you earn
different experience points that it lets
you like upgrade different things you
can like buy new equipment it's just a
really beautiful game and it's very fun
and drink box studios is really good at
making expressive art and that's why i
love severed
so as far as tax 2015 goes my favorite
moment was definitely the indie game by
two tribes call drive this is a
side-scroller a shooter we basically
took on three forms one in space one in
underwater and one as like a spider
Walker it was really cool about this was
you think of it's like a typical arcade
shooter but had a lot of Awesome like
mechanics where you get hack different
enemies around you and kind of put him
on your side so for instance there was
this boss and had like a med thought
that was giving it hell you hack it put
it on your side and it can follow you
for a short period of time just like
giving you shields and such but in
general is this a really like fluid good
looking game there were a lot of moments
where I was taken away by the attention
to detail for instance the shells of
your main gun would fire out and
depending on what environment you're in
they behave differently so in space they
kind of floated away in underwater they
kind of you know stay put and sink just
slightly and then on ground they would
behave like normal shells just you know
falling down I'm really looking forward
to it I believe it comes out sometime
this year 2015 but it was definitely one
my favorites
I discovered a pretty cool game at pax
this year it was called jotun and it is
a hands-on Dark Souls and I feel like it
really is that you are this tiny little
person you're a tiny Viking in this
massive world and the demo was playing
an enormous off he was massive and
you're sliding around on the ice but
what makes it really cool is this
hand-drawn feeling because I am a Viking
I have this sweet fur coat on and the
animation of the fur looks really nice
when I'm running around in this world so
I think it's really easy on the eyes I
thought it was a really good looking
game but i loved the fighting mechanic
its massive boss how I was even going to
start to try to take him down he had a
lot of sweet moves where he was a run
and charge me or he's like smash his
fifth on the ice in front of me so I had
to kind of chip away at him from his
toes but if I get him to trip I could
take out some of his face it was a task
that felt impossible and i love that
feeling i love a boss that makes me feel
like it is almost impossible
unsurmountable and then when i take them
down it feels so good so josan really
brought that out and i just think it's a
really cool game I think it's supposed
to be coming out in 2015 is what they
said and I'm looking forward to seeing
what other bosses they have a floor
so I actually spent a lot of time in
indy mega booth during pax this year and
if you go to the Indy mini boot there's
a couple of really cool games and one
that caught my eye is this game by a
one-man developer called 12 minutes it's
called 12 minutes because you keep
reliving the same 12 minutes in this
really strange eerie Groundhog Day style
scenario you're a man and you come home
and your wife is making you dinner and
you sit down to dinner and she tells you
that she's pregnant and you sort of
react poorly and then a cop busts in and
calls your wife by a different name
kicks you and her to the floor zip ties
your hands together and says you are
arrested for the murder of her father
and then everything starts over and you
know as the man you know that time is
restarting and you're living the same
day over and over and over but your wife
does not so you need to figure out in
those 12 minutes between when you come
home and the cops busting you need to
find a way to convince your wife that
time is restarting to figure out why
time is restarting and to figure out
what the cop means by calling your wife
by different name and accusing her of
murder it reminds me of Majora's Mask in
a way you have to live the same three
days over and over and over and over
until you get everything right and I
really like that mechanic I think it's
cool i'm really interested in it now
they say it's going to come out later
this year so i'm looking forward to
getting it
you
you